let's get into the listener and viewer
mailbag if you have something to say
it's info davidpackman.com sometimes we
will highlight a YouTube comment or a
tweet or what else it could be anything
but it's mostly emails sent to info
davidpackman.com we're going to start
today with Norma Jean Norma Jean is
upset
I find these emails a little funny
Norma Jean wrote in and said about
Michael Cohen with a sad face hi David I
discovered your show on Tick Tock and
have been listening to your podcast ever
since thank you for being a voice of
reason in a crazy time look forward and
look forward to subscribing one question
I was surprised that you would have
agreed to be on Michael Cohen's podcast
can you clarify and talk a little about
why you chose to be on his podcast given
his sketchy past to include tax and bank
fraud in addition to being disbarred by
the New York Supreme Court yikes how
does he have any credibility left thank
you yeah you know I mean listen
um I
appearing on a show
is not an endorsement of everything that
person has done and if you go down this
path sort of like where do you draw the
line I mean I'm sure everybody who's
interviewed me has lied some of them
have also cheated on their significant
others that arguably could be a reason
for me to refuse to appear on some other
shows I mean this isn't how I think
about things you know
um you get invited to lots of shows and
the question is is it worthwhile
speaking to the audience of that show
and the answer with Michael Cohen's show
was yes so I appeared on the show it's
it's really just that it doesn't mean
that I think it was okay when Michael
Cohen committed bank fraud or when some
other interviewer you know cheated on
their spouse as many of the people that
have interviewed me it's I'm not
endorsing anything in particular
I'm just doing the show so I I would
just say don't think too much about that
um yeah maybe I'll just leave it there
Andrew wrote in and said also be fun to
see you respond to this on one of your
videos don't you will as it is one of
your fake emails at the beginning I felt
your channel had potential but you went
extreme left and you now becoming a
failure no wonder you need to endorse
businesses that are scam for money you
are desperate you know what's really
funny
this is a really common so I've talked
about unsubscribed trolls right which
are
now I'm unsubscribing and it's like you
were never subscribed
uh this one is I used to have positive
feelings about your show but because of
the things you did I no longer do I went
back and checked out the email history
the reason so we keep all emails that
are sent in sometimes because law
enforcement needs them I know that
that's really sad but unfortunately in
this era
when you've been doing this as long as
we've been doing it and your audience is
a certain size it starts to become
likely that some of your viewers are
going to be entangled with law
enforcement
and uh we keep all records in case
um we may at some point need to turn
them over to law enforcement but also
just to see for example Andrew has been
writing in literally for years and every
email has been riddled with insults and
pejoratives and uh all sorts of stuff he
never thought that channel had potential
he's been insulting me since day one and
uh the other funny thing is now you're
becoming a failure the show is bigger
today than it has ever been before
might have been better earlier to say
your show will never be bigger or
something like that but okay that's
Andrew very very important message
um trolllay wrote in and said Trump
claims he can't be anti-semitic because
he moved the embassy to Jerusalem
so many Christians also seem to claim to
love Israel but they hate Jews
many fundamentalist Christians believe
it is their duty to bring about
Armageddon as a step to bring about the
Rapture do you think the president
actually did it to placate these people
as Jerusalem becoming the capital is a
step in that goal excellent question
I've explained so many times American
Jews are very liberal one of the most
left-wing voting blocs in the United
States and yet you often hear
but what about Republicans as the
supporters of Israel
Republicans support Israel in a very
narrow way that is connected to the
Evangelical beliefs about as this email
is pointing out the Rapture Armageddon
the second coming of Jesus etc etc they
don't like or or like isn't even the
right word
they aren't
about the Jewish people as a people as a
culture as a community
they believe their teachings in which
Jews and Israel have a particular role
to play in Jesus coming back and Rapture
and Armageddon and all of this other
crazy stuff and yes the Jerusalem thing
is part of that I don't know that Trump
had any idea about that Trump's view
most likely was
the people on my side who talk to me
about Israel
want the embassy in Jerusalem so that's
good and that's probably as far as Trump
really is aware but a very good question
and very accurately uh pointed out there
Michael wrote in about
oversimplification of political issues
and this is also a good topic says David
started watching a few months ago really
liked the show have you ever noticed how
many right-wing positions are based on
Gross oversimplification of the issues
climate change it still snows therefore
global warming is a hoax gender just
look between your legs poverty just work
harder immigration just come in Legally
mental illness just snap out of it
systemic oppression pull yourself up by
your bootstraps abortion it's always
murder STDs just don't have sex covet
vaccine you still get covid so it's
useless homelessness go to a shelter
drug addiction just stop using and it
makes sense you have to be that out of
touch with how things work for everyday
people to be a right winger yeah this is
this is a big academic topic and Michael
Michael may have stumbled upon this on
his own
but people like George lakeoff and
others have talked about how the framing
that the right uses for so many issues
is linguistically advantageous and it
contributes to the Simplicity we need
tax relief
taxes are a burden lower taxes people
are relieved that's good right but you
can't lower them to zero then Society
ceases to function abortion well I'm
pro-life everybody else must be against
life life is good so being this is
actually a really big Topic in the
American political divide and Michael is
completely right that the only way that
you would believe this stuff is if you
really are out of touch or lack
information or you know we've talked
about the different categories but this
is a this is a feature of Republican
politics not a bug because it makes it
so that completely untenable political
positions
seem almost viable to some people by
virtue of their fabricated simplicity
um Michael wrote in about conservative
Checkmate and says you should benefit
from how you are registered to vote if
you register as a conservative I guess
Michael means a republican you get to
keep your total wage and pay no taxes
but in return you get no Services no
police no fire no Health Care you would
have to pay out of pocket for those
Services if you register as a Democrat
you pay 30 to 40 percent in taxes but
you get health care Social Security fire
police Etc would conservatives be okay
with this idea now I know that this I
think anyway that this is a thought
experiment from Michael and it's one
we've explored before
um in practice I don't know what the
average right wing Winger would say
listen you get to keep all your money
but you've got to pay for every road
that you use I mean it sort of starts to
become kind of like one of these
libertarian Utopias which don't work at
all
um I don't know what they would say but
obviously we all know that this type of
thinking is completely impossible for
any functioning Society but it'd be a
curious one to uh to ask them about for
sure
Anthony wrote In from Spain and says I'm
a long time fan from Spain sorry for my
English it's my fourth language it's a
little subtle brag there I wanted to ask
you if you've ever consider doing some
Spanish language videos I want to
recommend you to some of my
acquaintances who do not believe me when
I tell them about how bad U.S politics
are I also hear there's loads of
disinformation in Spanish both here and
in the U.S and I don't know of any
Spanish-speaking equivalent to your show
I know it would probably have lower Roi
but you are one of the few that could
reach that public without sounding
condescending since you're a native
Spanish speaker so we've been looking to
do this for a while I just don't have
any time in my day to produce content in
Spanish in addition to what I'm doing
but we are about to Launch
a dubbed version of our Clips to Spanish
so you'll see me
The Voice will be dubbed into Spanish
and I know I know I know I know I know I
know it's not perfect it's not perfect I
just don't have any any more time guys
uh it you know we've got the live
streams and we've got the podcast and
the YouTube channel and the finance
Channel and you know my my daughters
needing diaper changes I thought I only
needed like three diapers for the entire
first year it turns out you need way
more than three diapers for that it's
crazy I just can't I can't do more
content in Spanish
so we're going to be doing a dubbing
thing I think it could do quite well and
I'll tell you more about it when it uh
when it launches Landon wrote in about
Trump and says past presidents have
airports named after them perhaps a
prison can be named after Trump of
course preferably with him locked inside
nice one Landon I'm I'm that's a
presented without comment I won't even
comment on that and then Dwayne wrote in
about voter fraud and says David I'm
curious as to how many cases of voter
fraud that have been prosecuted from
2020 to the end of 22 have been
Republicans compared to Democrats I keep
seeing a case it seems like every other
week and it is not a Democrat it's as if
any claim a republican makes of a crime
is basically an admission of a crime
they have done I may not be a smart man
but I know I'm seeing a pattern here
thank you Dwight yeah so you know part
of this is does some voter fraud go
uh under the radar but of the prosecuted
cases in the U.S and there are very few
it is overwhelmingly Republicans and
it's often Republicans trying to prove a
point and then the prove they point the
point they prove is the opposite they
want to prove how easy it is to get away
with it then they get caught
um Sometimes some Republicans were
caught genuinely voting twice like for
their some in some cases a dead relative
we've seen these things anecdotally big
picture there's very little voter fraud
happening at the micro level for those
who get prosecuted it is mostly
Republicans Dwayne is absolutely correct
send in your thoughts comments questions
to info
davidpackman.com sign up at
joinpakman.com to get all of our great
member benefits including instant access
to the bonus show which you could go
watch or listen to right now if you were
already a member